[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
looks like we have some sound issues
i'm not sure exactly what's going on
[Music]
holy moly i hope you can hear me out
there can you hear me can you hear me
okay
must be that uh dark brandon
dark brandon's out there
let's talk about our democracy oh
but let's do it in a way that makes the
city no
there we go there we go hey how are you
this morning what a morning we have
empty folders we have a whole list of
documents that we got to get through we
have bonehead of the week because it is
friday even though we have sound issues
here did you guys experience the sound
issues like i was experiencing there
ain't they sit down you said you can
hear me i don't know i don't know what
was going on with the um
with the music there was the music weird
i think it was dark brandon um
oh manga is upset this morning they're
upset this morning that
joe biden is rallying democracy to
defeat them they're very scared they're
terrified and as a matter of fact i'm so
terrified that they're using the i'm
rubber your glue
that's their strategy i'm rubber your
glue what bounces off me sticks to you
look there was a red light behind him
that makes him a nazi
really is dumb
it really is dumb he's standing in front
of independence hall in philadelphia
he gave a speech about
democracy folks
it was about the fundamentals of
democracy
hello
think mcfly think
a speech about democracy
and the fundamentals of democracy and
how important our way of life is because
of democracy
is not fascist you are the [ __ ]
who want to tear down our democracy
that's what he was saying that that's
that's the that was the whole point of
the whole goddamn thing
is that there are domestic terrorists
they're even calling themselves that
they want to use violence they're
calling for violence for riots
if their orange dd is held accountable
for the crimes that he committed
speaking of crimes that he committed
where in the [ __ ] are those top secret
classified documents
where the [ __ ] are they there's folders
there's folders baby but there's not
documents
i wonder i wonder how many folders it
takes
to hold two billion dollars worth of top
secret documents maybe we could maybe we
could go to jared
i'm just saying there must be a
commercial in there somewhere
but they're freaking out this morning
freaking out lauren bobert says we're a
friendly reminder we're a constitutional
republic i don't know how many times i
have to [ __ ] go over this
i know how many times i have to yell and
scream this into the [ __ ] microphone
would you please clip this and share it
with your manga stupid relatives or just
tag lauren bobert for crying out loud so
she can get a [ __ ] handle on this
[ __ ] look
we are a constitutional republic
we are a democratic constitutional
republic where we democratically elect
our representatives you [ __ ] bonehead
and we become more democratic as we've
went on in this country
originally the senate was not
democratically elected it was appointed
and we decided as a democracy that
that's what we should do we should make
it more democratic
it really is a [ __ ] bonehead [ __ ] and
bonehead speaking of bonehead we have
bonet of the week
today bonehead of the week you know it's
friday in the second hour of the show on
friday we go through the bonehead of the
week poll you can follow us on
tonymichaelspod
on twitter the poll is over there every
single week you vote you decide who is
the bonehead of the week and we break it
down in the second hour
so don't forget to subscribe to the tony
michaels podcast we're here every single
weekday not just fridays monday through
friday two full hours noon eastern 11
central nine pacific we just happened to
do our favorite segment bonehead of the
week
in the second hour you can also download
every single episode on apple spotify
google while you're there do us a huge
favor and leave us a review and
subscribe
to the tony michaels podcast on your
favorite directory
boy do we have some boneheaded attorneys
what did you guys think of the poll we
were like you know what we should have a
theme this week and the theme should be
bone-headed attorneys
they did not they did not let us down
did they
and [ __ ] boneheads i can't wait i
can't wait to hear the dog the dog ate
my top secret documents out of those
folders that's why them folders are
empty i told you i told you i doubt me
they were gonna use the dog ate my
homework defense
it was coming it's coming in it's coming
in now they're like oh well we
he really lacks top secret folders as
mementos
what
i mean you know there's a couple
different reasons why you'd have a
shitload
of empty classified folders
i mean there's a couple reasons
i mean number one you [ __ ] stole them
that's one reason
but you'd you wanna stick stuff in them
that's not classified and act like it's
classified that could be something
i mean i guess that's a reason you know
you're trying to get clout classified
clout i guess
you know you print off a few of your
dick pics and you stick them in there
this is classified
you know
it seems like a pickup line he would use
come on come on don't you think
but the other reason why you would have
a bunch of uh a stack ass full load of
classified folders that are
empty is because maybe you took the
information out of the folders
maybe maybe you i don't know
maybe maybe you ate them i mean he seems
to like to eat things
just saying i don't know how classified
documents taste
but he might have an affinity for
classified documents they just might
have this
certain
um
i don't know do you dip them in ketchup
do you dip classified documents ketchup
i don't know i don't know
the other thing yeah i mean you could
say maybe just maybe maybe just maybe
they made their way to a certain golf
tournament
i don't know it could be that they made
their way to a golf tournament and that
was the payment for the golf tournament
the other thing you could say is
jared kushner got two billion dollars i
don't know maybe maybe maybe that's
where they went i don't know
also
can we all agree that we need to search
this cemetery
for whatever the hell's in that casket
come on
come on i mean now that we know that
there's like a thousand [ __ ]
classified document bowlers that are
[ __ ] empty and that's that's probably
why they [ __ ] moved on him like a
[ __ ]
there's got to be something that [ __ ]
casket right
am i wrong am i am i an [ __ ] is it
too [ __ ] soon i don't know i just i
think there's gotta be something in that
casket other than a bag of ashes he
didn't there's no way you put her in an
urn
it's in a [ __ ] plastic baggie
probably not even a ziploc probably like
a off brand you know that doesn't seal
worth the [ __ ] when you put it in the
freezer it gets freezer burn and [ __ ]
you know what i'm talking about
he probably put her in some shitty ass
plastic sack
i'm just saying there's no way there's
no way he spent money on the urn i mean
the casket where you're gonna store
highly classified documents away from
the government that have to do with
january 6 that you don't want anyone to
know or your corruption and collusion
and obstruction
that you are trying to cover up from i
don't know 2016 maybe you'll bury those
i don't know it's hard to tell i mean
remember
he waved his big mac stained hands over
these documents and declassified them so
maybe when he does that you know what
maybe that there you go there's another
reason there is another reason how
that's how those folders could get empty
is when he waves his big mac stained
hands over these classified folders and
declassified everything they just
disappear poof gone
i mean it's like a magic trick you don't
think of it that way a mcdonald's magic
trick
i don't know i'm trying i'm trying to
come up with a damn good reason why
these [ __ ] folders are empty
where'd our goddamn documents go that's
what i want to know where in the [ __ ]
did our documents go that's our [ __ ]
that's our government [ __ ] that's us
that we're the government that's our
[ __ ]
where the [ __ ] did it go
i mean is that what was in melania's
underwear drawer i don't know i'm just
trying to figure this stuff out
these are questions that should be asked
the weirdest [ __ ] part about this
whole thing the weirdest [ __ ] part
about this whole goddamn thing
is the only reason why we know this the
only reason why we know now
that he stole
treasure troves
billions of dollars
of top secret documents
the reason why we know that he was
hiding them between the time
picture the time magazine picture frames
the reason why we know
that he had three in his desk drawer
the reason why we know
now that he had that he there's a
shitload of top secret classified
document folders with no documents in
them they're [ __ ] empty
it's because of trump
like literally this all this stuff all
the picture that we got uh
knowing what cash to tell had to do with
it knowing now that his [ __ ] lawyers
lied they [ __ ] lied on those
affidavits when they said yes we
returned everything
we returned it all
now we know there's
closed caption
closed circuit television security
cameras of them moving boxes around
after they were told not to [ __ ]
touch those boxes
we know that
and now this morning we know
that there's a shitload
of classified documents missing poof
gone just disappeared out of their
folders
don't exist
nope
see you
and we all know this because of trump's
dumb ass
that's why we know this
because he was like oh they're trying to
take my [ __ ] it's not your [ __ ] dude
i mean if you look at that list there's
a ton of [ __ ] pictures
they're government pictures and they're
probably of him there's i mean or of
some beautiful woman standing there next
to him there's no way that that [ __ ]
guy took pictures of of of the white
house or or our nation's capital or
other things it's only at hand those
pictures only have him on
and he thinks because he's in the
pictures he owns them no dummy those are
government
photos those are our archives
he still does not [ __ ] get it he
doesn't get it he doesn't get what his
job was
he doesn't understand he won't ever
understand he won't get it
he's too [ __ ] narrow-minded too
simple-minded he's a dumb [ __ ] he will
not get it
that he held our office he had the
pleasure of serving as the president of
the united states
everything that he did there was ours
was in service of us
he doesn't get it you know who does get
it
you know he does understand this
and they're [ __ ] pissed off about it
that he gets it oh they're [ __ ]
they're livid they're livid that this
guy understands what democracy is that
this guy understands
exactly what the office of presidency is
he understands what actual populism real
populism is
like he cares about the [ __ ] american
people over himself or his donors or his
party
joe biden last night we watched him give
a speech
that is gonna go down is probably one of
the best speeches i i believe john
meacham wrote this speech because it was
about the soul of the nation john
meacham has a book called the soul of
the nation i'm not sure if that's
confirmed or not but i think i think
john meacham had a lot to do with this
speech
it's historic
it's historic never has in our time
never has a president of the united
states have to come out halfway through
his first term
and talk about how the supporters of the
last president who he beat by 8 million
votes are a bunch of goddamn terrorists
never in our [ __ ] lifetimes that we
had this happen and we may not have this
happen again i don't know depends on how
quickly they crawl back underneath their
rocks they don't seem to want to go back
underneath there but it just depends
but think about that for a second
think about it
the president united states came out
yesterday into a microphone in prime
time
and had to [ __ ]
absolutely
castigate a certain group of people in
this country who want to tear down our
[ __ ] government who want to tear down
our democracy who want to do away with
our way of life
and you know what their response was do
you know what the house republicans
response was college football is better
than joe biden
what you [ __ ] want to abolish
the department of education
where in the [ __ ] do you think college
football comes from you dumb
[ __ ]
you really need to pick a [ __ ] lane
this is stupid this is dumb we why can't
why can't we gather up as as a [ __ ]
country and tell them to shut the [ __ ]
up you are dumb [ __ ]
you're you're complaining about the
department of education they've been
complaining about college and
universities how they brainwash people
colleges are the worst thing ever you
shouldn't even get a college education
because they're just brainwashing you
into being liberals in other words
they're educating you
giving you i don't know [ __ ] like facts
teaching you history it's how to add
subtract
oh my god
whoosh
but they're they they're really excited
about college last night
real excited about the department of
education last night oh they like them
some student athletes
when they're when they're in a
competition with joe biden who is
delivering a message who is going to
eviscerate them
because that's why they're freaking out
this morning manga is freaking out this
morning it's because biden is rallying
democracy to defeat them
we've been doing it here for months and
months and months [ __ ] he said the same
[ __ ] i've been saying engage in your
democracy do you remember that part of
the speech
how long have i been saying that doubt
me
doubt me i've been saying
engaging your democracy for months
for months i've been telling you to
engage in your democracy you've been
listening because the audience is
growing
so i only have to assume that you're
sharing the show with your family and
your friends and you're doing the thing
that democracies do is engage in their
ballot
and have conversations and you're
talking to people
i have to believe that's what it is i
think that's what it is that's why our
audience is growing by leaps and bounds
every single week
we have record audiences
because you guys aren't just listening
here you're going out and you're you're
participating
you're doing what the citizens of a
constitutional republic
should do
which is democratically
participate
in their way of life in their country
not [ __ ] try to tear [ __ ] down not
try to break [ __ ] not try to abolish our
our great democratic institutions like
the department of education
because because student loans and
colleges and universities
need reform
this is really stupid
last night joe biden made a case for
democracy
and i believe there's americans out
there that heard him say the words
not just the [ __ ]
stupid memes
that they're trying to put out
marjorie taylor green puts out a video
she can't she can't play what joe biden
actually said
like they can't do that they can't play
a clip of what joe biden actually said
because if they did that americans would
be like well yeah that's why we voted
for this guy
like the speech last night
i mean
come on am i wrong the speech last night
he gives the speech if at all americans
had to listen to it and had to give
their opinion
81 million people 81 million who voted
for him would be like well yeah that's
why we voted for that guy like we voted
for that guy instead of the other guy
because the other guy wanted autocracy
this guy wanted democracy and we want
democracy we do not want autocracy
that's why we made that decision
and that's your decision in a few months
for the midterm
you're just your decision you have to
make in a few months is autocracy or
democracy and i know most of you here
besides a few of the trolls
who are who are maga cult members and
they're here
they're here we have manga cult members
in the chat and they're welcome here
because we want to try to change their
minds
they're bone eds but they might it might
not be a permanent bone head injury just
might be a temporary bone-headed tree
but we welcome them here at the tony
michael's podcast
maybe they'll hear the words
because marjorie taylor green puts out a
video
oh it's oh it's hilarious it's hilarious
they put swastikas up behind him they
put a hitler mustache on him and you
know what they can't play his words so
they have to play a hitler speech they
have to dub hitler over him
because they can't play his words
because that's not what he said
he didn't say anything that was fascist
you [ __ ] morons
the reason why he calls you fascist the
reason why he calls you the enemy of
democracy you manga republicans and i
hate how he says that to be honest with
you they're america first nazis
they're they're trumpers
they're [ __ ] they're american fascist
fascism in a maga hat
to call them republicans
only only says that they're not
only says that they're not
the enemy yes they are
they are the enemy
they declared themselves domestic
terrorist at cpac at the nazi rally the
nuremberg rally
in texas where hungarian hitler the
fascist dictator in hungary orban came
and spoke and they all stood up and
clapped and cheered
yay hungarian hitler yay
he hates gay people he wants to kill
brown people yay
they love that
because they're fascist and that's why
they're really pissed off here they're
really [ __ ] mad that you
the people are catching on that these
people don't want democracy well who to
thunk it when they [ __ ] overturn
people's rights to their bodily autonomy
when they're trying to ban book fairs
they're trying to in florida they're
banning books in florida they're burning
books in florida they're trying to marry
children in tennessee
they can't focus on anything anything
but someone else's [ __ ] genitalia i
mean just they can't do it there's
nothing more important than someone
else's genitalia let me tell you with
these [ __ ] fascists
it's like when they go in the bathroom
they can't concentrate on anything else
when they go in schools they can't
concentrate on anything else
jesus christ big dick energy that's all
they that's all carrie lake talks about
apparently on stage
is genitalia they just can't stop
focusing on weird ass [ __ ] because
they're [ __ ] weirdo fascist
that's what they are
and that's why they're mad that we're
calling them that because they're now
very well branded i mean they kind of
did it to themselves
we just pointed it out like oh yeah
that's fascist oh that's fascist oh what
you're doing there ron desantis yeah
that's fish oh greg abbott oh you you
want to make sure that women get taken
back to the 16th century yeah greg
abbott that's fascist
oh you want to ban contraception you
want to ban medical procedures ah that's
fascist
you want to tell people who they can
love and who they can't love that's
fascist we're just pointing it out and
they're [ __ ] pissed off that we're
pointing it out
so much so that they're using the i'm
rubber your glue
defense that's literally what they're
doing this morning oh you're a fascist
jill budden
okay
all right yeah the guy who just gave a
speech in defense of democracy defensive
voting of equality and equity
and progression is fascist you are some
dumb sons of [ __ ]
democracy is not easy he even said it
it's [ __ ] difficult and that's why
liberalism is not weak get the [ __ ] out
of here with that [ __ ] the weak the weak
ideology
in this world is the one that looks to
one [ __ ] to tell them what to
say to tell them what to do
oh i'm supposed to believe that you own
these top secret documents and you
weren't stealing them to profit from
them and and take them away from us oh
i'll believe it
must be an overdue library book
oh the fbi are slobs so that makes them
criminal not
me and they'll go along with it
because they're a cult but more than
anything they're fascist and fascism and
autocracy is [ __ ] simple it's easy
liberalism democracy western liberal
democracy is [ __ ] difficult
it's [ __ ] hard it's not easy to
[ __ ] disagree with half the people
you're supposed to agree with
especially when you're trying to set
policy but the one thing that democrats
have never been able to do but they're
starting to figure it out is that and
i've been saying it i've been saying it
just go [ __ ] watch the old episodes
if you're a new listener there's two
things here at play there's government
which is policy and there's elections
which is the politics
and you don't get the set policy you
don't get to do government that's not a
thing you get to do if you don't play
politics
and you have to politicize every
[ __ ] thing everything all of it
the whole [ __ ] and caboodle like this
morning this list where this son of a
[ __ ] had
dozens and dozens of empty classified
folders
we have to politicize the ever living
[ __ ] out of that yesterday when joe
biden gave a speech to democracy and all
they can do this morning
is to dub over him with hitler because
they can't play his words they can't
play his words because if they play his
words to their audiences the audience
will go well he's talking about
democracy what what do you mean
he they can't play his words because his
speech was about democracy
what about fascism what about american
carnage
stephen miller donald trump the [ __ ] out
of here
we are not in dark days
we are in brighter days jesus christ the
[ __ ] jobs report comes out this
morning the two good things out of the
job report is after a record month last
month of having more than a half a
million jobs created we have 300 000
jobs created
and and more people entered the
workforce so much so that it affected
the goddamn unemployment rate
people are coming back to the workforce
isn't that what republicans wanted
oh just put donald trump charged and
everybody would have a job
well it looks like the policies of joe
biden and the democrats are actually
fixing the [ __ ] economy are actually
making sure unemployment's row and more
people are entering the workforce so
that we have i don't know an expanded
economy
so the contrast is stark
it's stark and joe biden laid it out
last night and you can see it no more
this morning than their arguments for
why last night's speech was horrible
because he had a red light behind him
that that's that's their argument this
morning i don't know if you watch but he
had a red light behind him
oh yeah and there's there's two marines
back there which are always there when a
president speaks i don't know if you
went back and you looked at any of these
pictures while trump and bush obama
reagan
h.w bush i don't know if you went back
and looked at any of those pictures
there's [ __ ] military people at
standing at attention right behind some
[ __ ] when he's speaking this is really
[ __ ] dumb so the red light which they
drown out the blue because they had the
wrong [ __ ] angle
we had on our feed on the midas touch
feed we had the blue light and the red
light it didn't look like they're
showing on the internet
but that's the one he's got a red light
and he's got some marines behind him
that son of a [ __ ] that that nazi
bastard what are you talking about ron
desantis has let's go brandon nazis at
disney at overpasses in florida
charlie kirk that nazi piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] who was on fox news going oh i'm a
fascist with joe biden's a fascist again
i'm rubber you're glue charlie kirk held
a turning points usa student event in
florida and there was nazis real [ __ ]
nazis real [ __ ] nazi flags saying
real [ __ ] nazi [ __ ] if it walks like
a nazi if it talks like a nazi it's a
[ __ ] nazi
outside turning points usa
all the white supremacy groups they they
aren't in support of the democratic
party or joe biden they [ __ ] hate him
they [ __ ] hate joe biden
the white supremacy groups the pair
militia groups
proud boys you think the proud boys are
on joe biden's side
give me a [ __ ] break they're freaking
out this morning because it's working
folks
they're losing
we're winning and democracy wins when
you engage in it i'm telling you just
look at what happened in alaska with
sarah palin look what happened in new
york's 19th
with pat ryan look what happened in
kansas with the referendum where the
kansans told the republican fascist
legislator
no you will not take our [ __ ] rights
away from us you can go to [ __ ] hell
it's happening
you watch the videos of beto events you
see how fetterman is dunking
dr oz in the trash
warnock doesn't even have to hardly say
a goddamn thing because herschel walker
says all the wrong [ __ ]
we have them on their heels folks
they're on the run
that's why they're scared this morning
that's why they're terrified that joe
biden came out last night in prime time
right before labor day weekend
think about this right before labor day
weekend the president united states
comes out in front of a microphone in
front of the entire country
and tells them
what's at stake
and rallies democracy
he's rallying democracy he's rallying
the people
is what he's doing
and he's asking you to engage
and he's asking you
to do your civic duty and save the your
way of life
the schools the community centers the
churches you don't think they're going
to get rid of your church you don't
think they're going to get rid of your
school
jesus christ you haven't been listening
to this show then we've been showing
these white christian nationalists they
don't want you to educate people in
public schools they don't want you to go
to a church other than a white christian
nationalist church
they're fascists they're nazis they're
america first nazis
and they're really terrified the doc
that donald trump is the head guy
of their fascist regime and he's [ __ ]
he's completely [ __ ] here they're
terrified that he's he's he's oh my god
is he done but the thing that really
upsets them the most this morning is
that joe biden sleepy joe biden
he's not so sleepy anymore is he
dark brandon comes out last night and he
rallies democracy to defeat
maga
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after this break
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too hardened blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa
don't delay and get your pardon blanket
today for just
99.99 actual partying's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
i have no idea what is happening with
our graphics and sound
very strange
going crazy
i thought it was just in the front of
the show
[Music]
very weird
must be that deep state i don't know it
must be that deep state
i have no idea does it sound weird to
you guys it sounds horrible to me
it says you can hear
does it sound weird it sounds okay okay
well it's just on my end it's just on my
end i i'm getting weird sounds in my ear
so maybe maybe it's just me it could be
just me
i have no idea that
someone says are you being hacked i
don't know i don't think i mean that
i don't think i'm being act yeah mj says
it might be sorrows
yeah it might be soros i don't know um i
you know
i've been waiting on my paycheck but
maybe i didn't pay my soros bill i don't
know i have no idea
no it might be my headphones i have no
idea but it looks like it's freezing and
the sound is going out on my end here
that's why that's why i was a couple
minutes late i was trying to figure it
out i was trying to reset some things
and
make some adjustments so it worked
speaking of mjmj thank you for the great
moderation in the chat here along with
minus robin and minus margie our three
moderators give the moderators some love
it's friday before labor day weekend we
want everyone to be safe for the holiday
but make sure make sure before you leave
today the show
to give the moderators some love in the
chat
they do such a great job they keep us on
our toes
now they let us know problems that we
have during before and after the show so
thank you to the three moderators mj
robin and margie we appreciate you guys
being here and and all you in the chat
should appreciate them being here
they're they're helping they're helping
moderate the chat and keeping um making
sure that the people who want to be
trolls nice trolls you know that want to
troll respectfully they're welcome here
you're welcome here if you disagree with
me i i don't give a [ __ ] you can come
here and listen to me all you want i
want hate watchers we have chris inn
always in the chat
we have chris in all the time he's here
and we got a few others we got fake gabe
over on facebook fake gabe joins us
he's not as respectful as chris in but
you know he's getting there
fake gabe is getting there
but look we we are
we are we are growing the audience
there's more and more folks joining us
here at the johnny michaels podcast so i
want to take a chance to tell you
exactly what happens on friday
because we're going to get to it at the
top of the other gabe's going to join us
in just a few minutes for [ __ ] list
roundup here's what we do with the [ __ ]
list roundup we round up all the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends from the
day we go through the news it's
basically what it is i call it the
shitless roundup now
and on friday in the second hour we do a
special segment called bone end of the
week
bone end of the week is a poll that we
put out on twitter and it's also here on
youtube so don't forget to subscribe
while you're here
set the bell notification for youtube so
you can vote every week on youtube and
you can also vote on twitter follow us
on twitter at tonymichaelspod you can
vote there every single week so here's
what happens
you vote for the bonehead of the week
you decide we like to practice democracy
here we practice every single week
you vote you decide who is the bonehead
of the week and me and the great gabe
sanchez break it down in the second hour
on friday now there's a new change this
is a great change too
every friday night we replay bonehead of
the week we used to replay it on sundays
but we've changed the replay to friday
nights in prime time on the midas touch
network's youtube channel
so don't forget when you're done here
with the show today go check out the
midas touch networks youtube channel and
subscribe over there they're breaking
news over there they have plenty of
reactions over there we've seen some of
our clips over there but bonehead of the
week will play every single friday in
prime time
on a replay for you guys to re-watch in
and of itself also you can download
bonehead of the week
every single week as you can every
single episode of the tony michaels
podcast on apple spotify and google
while you're there make sure to leave us
a great review and subscribe
on your favorite on your favorite
directory
oh boy we have a lot of stuff to get
into i want to show you this list this
list of empty boulders um i actually
believe that's probably why they have
the espana espionage charge on there
like this is the reason why they felt it
to be so
rushed they felt like they really had to
go in and get because they don't know
where this [ __ ] is disappearing too
um with these empty folders sitting
around everywhere so let's get into that
let's get into
going through a little bit of biden
speech before we get to
the bonehead of the week let's start the
shitless roundup let's surf the tweety
tweets and trendy trends let's start the
countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome welcome to the
[ __ ] list roundup
we
where we round up all the tweety tweets
and trendy trends i'm telling you
something's going funky over here with
the graphics and the sound something's
weird something's weird i don't know
maybe it doesn't sound weird where
you're at but where i'm at it sounds
weird and it's doing all kinds of weird
things
but we're going to get through it we're
going to surf the twisty tweets and the
trendy trends we don't relent here we do
not give up here we we barrel through
technical difficulties here at the tony
michaels podcast we will not stop we
will not quit
so stick with us so we got to get
through
oh
some of the tweety tweets and trendy
trends let's go to the bigger screen
here so you can see well let's see here
here we go here is the um i i tweeted
this earlier i said how many folders
does it take to hold two billion dollars
worth of classified documents
i'm just saying
i was telling you earlier this is one of
the reasons what i can think of why
there's [ __ ] empty folders why would
there be empty folders
i mean either took the empty folders or
empty the folders one or the other
it can't i mean
it can't be both
he couldn't have taken empty folders and
then not had anything empty out of him
he couldn't have taken folders that had
[ __ ] in them and now they're empty and
not taking [ __ ] out of them
where is the [ __ ] classified
documents that belong in these folders
here is the list
and here's just one uh portion of the
list this is one image that someone has
posted here
you can see
[Music]
documents from office here
us government documents
with secret classification two us
government
documents photographs without classified
documents or classified markings now so
he's got a lot of photos
right the other thing too he's got a
shitload of magazines i was telling you
this yesterday i was saying it yesterday
this [ __ ] brags about this
garbage he brags about it it's bragging
rights they keep saying it's mementos
and trinkets and [ __ ] it's that's not
what it is it is [ __ ] bragging rights
it's like trophies to him look what i
got
look what my face is on looky here look
at this look at that that's why he hangs
all that garbage on his wall that has
his face on it why he's got all the
stacks of magazines and newspapers on
his desk
i showed you that yesterday the photo of
it hell we might still have it here to
show later
well maybe when gage comes on we can
pull that picture up again so i can show
you again
buddy 99 magazines news p p newspapers
press articles
99
just one shine 100 two u.s government
documents with confidential
classified markings
15 u.s government documents with secret
now this is in the box in the office
this is the one probably with the
[ __ ] frames in it
okay
this is the one where they got them
sprawled out on the floor because they
found them in the box with the [ __ ]
time magazine frame
covers and they pull them out they stuck
them on the floor so they could take a
[ __ ] picture of them to have evidence
of what the hell was in that box here it
is
here it is
seven u.s government documents with top
secret classification markings
69 u.s government photos
are documents without classified so
those are probably pictures of him
doing the thumbs up
he's got he's
he's got he's got several hundred
pictures of him standing in front of who
god knows what would god knows who with
thumbs up that's literally what that
probably is doubt me
[ __ ] doubt me i almost bet all 69 of
those pictures are of him
almost all of them
now um this graphic here has the red box
around the most significant
itemization on this list 43 empty
folders with classified banners
so he's got empty folders
why does he have empty folders
and then there's there's over almost 30
empty folders labeled return to staff
our staff secretary military
hmm
seems like something's missing it seems
like that's why they took it all out of
the [ __ ] box and took a picture of it
don't you think that's probably why
oh they made a mess they made me look
like a slop they don't have to make you
look like a slob you are a slob
they took the [ __ ] documents out of
the box to take a picture of it so they
could get have some sort of verification
of this list
in real time
like ben mizella said last night
when we were doing the the the special
edition of the midas touch podcast i
don't know if you guys uh uh noticed but
we actually uh helped them do a live
production yesterday
of their podcast we did their podcast
live with the remarks that biden gave at
independence hall in philadelphia on
democracy
and ben mizella's
so brilliant brilliantly
brought up do you really think that the
fbi when these fbi photographers were
taking this evidence photos that they
thought they were going to be
broadcasting this all over twitter [ __ ]
no
hell to the no they thought that those
pictures would never see the lie today
they're only doing it to collect
evidence really honestly even in their
[ __ ] even in
some of these court filings they are
admitting that all this [ __ ] is
classified because they have to have
people get special clearance to see
these son of a [ __ ]
so they're only admitting that this
stuff is still [ __ ] top secret secret
confidential and classified and it has
to do with national defense information
because you have to have a special
designation to see some of this [ __ ]
because it's [ __ ] sensitive
information and it can put our [ __ ]
country at risk
yay what do you make of these these
empty folders what do you think i i'm
i'm trying to i'm trying to figure out
did he steal the empty boulders that's
not that can't be it because he can't
i've stole the empty boulders well you
got it hold on hold on you got to back
up what i hear what i really think is
different than what magga thinks so this
is what i think
i think that he stole these documents he
had them in classified banners folders
whatever
and those documents are either in
someone else's hands
in a coffin let's say somewhere in bed
mister
uh or in another trump residence
now
what i can imagine magga is going to say
is whoa whoa whoa what's the big deal
they were just empty classified folders
which you have to then wonder why would
he have so many empty classified folders
and they're going to double down on some
dumb argument to say that trump was
again
scrapbooking he was just he was just
memento collecting is what he was doing
but it seems very weird that you would
need multiple folders that were just
empty because there's nothing different
on the outside it says classified you
know maybe some information but other
than it like what do you what are you
really getting out of this i mean it's
all also revealing information i would
imagine is on those top cover sheets on
the folder probably as an indicator of
what it is about
so
for them they're going to argue that oh
there's nothing wrong they were just
empty what's the big crime
but it's what comes before that which is
where did those files go right where do
the documents go
they're either
in the white house in the mar-a-lago
plumbing in a coffin in another
residence
or maybe he ate them i don't know you
know
but i mean i guess i guess it's possible
that he he could have ate them i mean
and maybe that's where they went that's
maybe he's like i am like instead of
being like i declassified everything
he's like
the actual process
to declassify is to ingest it
and then
let it out the other end you know well i
mean and then it's declassified against
that point well the other thing too
the other thing too is he could wave his
hands his big mac stained hands over
this
and he actually could uh
make them disappear maybe that's what
happened
oh so he's a magician now i well i mean
it seems we've given him a lot of credit
i don't know i don't know you know
what's funny about this
do i sound funny to you
no do i sound funny oh my god this my
audio over here is completely
normal
it's it's mine can you can ask the
audience does no no they would they
would say no i've been asking them every
time i play a graphic or something it's
slow
it's like slow motion
you seem completely off but the obvious
you seem
it is weird it's going to take me a
little bit so if i seem like i'm off if
the timing's off is because
i'm
i'm way behind or something over here
something's going on oh my god
well you are two hours ahead of me
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no not not not like that not like okay
not and so not like time travel stuff no
no no no okay
[Laughter]
oh my god so this folder thing now this
is just one example of the empty folders
or are they gonna are they gonna argue
that he declassified empty folders
well i mean i guess they could if he's
gonna be like i declassified the
documents okay where were the where are
these documents and he goes well i i
declassified them
right they're just poof gone
right and they're like wait a second you
think when you declassify things they
disappear
that's probably what he believes i don't
know but i'm sure magga's gonna think
the same thing they're gonna be like oh
well
there was nothing even in those boulders
to declassify so then why did trump say
he declassified them
you're gonna you're gonna find that
they're going to continue to dig this
whole like it is just that gif of like
uh what's her face from scrubs where
she's like i'm just digging my own grave
here
because that's what they're doing
it's more it's more like the gift where
the kid gets the shovel full of dirt and
throws it oh and throws in his face
right here
but that's what they do they're they
continue to double down on these dumb
ass takes like oh he just took it home
or it was by mistake or he declassified
them or there was nothing there
important like all of these things
and so now they the doj every time is
like look we don't want to release this
stuff
but every time you do something and you
challenge us and the you know whoever
the judge is says yeah we need you to
release a bit more it doesn't look any
better
like it gets worse and worse the more
information that is revealed along the
way
looks worse now they're like oh you had
these empty folders whoa where did the
documents go that were inside those
folders
well i mean do they have ketchup on them
is there a residue of ketchup inside the
folder
it is a concern isn't it because you're
like
if the national archives doesn't have
them and these agencies don't have them
and these skip locations don't have them
and trump has the folders
you have to wonder where the [ __ ] that
hat like where did it go wrong it didn't
fall off the back of a truck i can tell
you that much
it made its way down to mar-a-lago now
the question is where else is it right
did he bury it
well i mean maybe it's in a cemetery
somewhere a specific cemetery yeah i
don't know
it seems really weird and it's again it
seems it's just a dumb thing like
the more and more they double down on
these arguments the more and more they
look like [ __ ] idiots which is fine
because it's not really hard to make
them look like idiots
but when they double down in this
fashion there's like there's really no
way for you to maneuver out of this
because you've now said
he had them and then he admitted to
having them and he admitted to having
cartons of them and then he admitted to
saying that he declassified them so
again what is he declassifying there's
no documents in those folders
you know
there's another story that
this morning and i think they're trying
to distract from this empty folders
thing
is that joe biden
um because he stood in front of a red
light uh there was a big red light yeah
he was um
you know he's hitler because there was a
red light and oh by the way by the way
he did what all the other presidents did
before him they just said differently
that that there's marines behind him did
you yeah did you see how how joe biden's
a fascist because he had a red light and
the two marines yeah i saw the people
well i saw the people last night that
were immediately like i've seen this
before and they're like it's the guy
from v for vendetta oh jesus christ
you fixed this thing for us yeah yeah
yeah i i i did a little touch-up dark
brandon
rises here is the you know the redo now
what's funny
what's funny about this is they they
they're focusing on the red light behind
him yeah and marjorie taylor green even
had to she put that th someone put like
schwanski up on the red lights and then
they couldn't
like play what joe biden's actually said
because if they played what he actually
said it wouldn't it wouldn't sound
anything like a nazi because he was
talking about democracy which is the
opposite of autocracy like
and and what is funny about that is they
had to actually dub over hitler's voice
over him because they couldn't play what
he said
right
but here is here is uh
especially because they i saw the
hashtag uh pedo
hitler
yeah yeah
i find that funny for the reason that
the people who are pushing that hashtag
are the people that backed
a dude
who raped 26 women
who said he could grab women by the
[ __ ] because you know that's what they
want
and that's what and he can get away with
it right you know he's the guy who you
know parties with epstein
right
he's
uh he has him over to the resort there's
video of him you know we already know
trump has this weird sort of like uh
uh incestuous uh kind of desire for his
daughter ivanka right you know
it's very weird he has a very [ __ ]
weird relationship with women his
daughter and the overall sense of
of uh just children too i don't know if
you've ever seen footage of him kissing
kids it's like when people like oh uh
joe biden kissed a kid on the forehead
right if you look at footage from 2020
of president uh or former president um
trump on the campaign trail like there's
a girl who introduced him at like a
colle it was like a cpac thing or like a
college summit and he like tried to go
for kiss and she was like not really
having it and he was like
get the [ __ ] uh then he he at the same
the same uh
or a different a different uh kind of
rally or convention he was kissing these
kids and these kids were like
not not about it at all
and then he's also [ __ ] groping the
american flag and kissing it like this
dude is weird right so when people talk
about like oh biden is this is pedophile
or whatever it's like no
what you're doing right now is
projecting
your own creep right which is donald
trump on to another guy
well and not only that they support the
alleged pedophile matt gats and he's a
fascist well that's the thing the group
that is you know save the children we
want to we want to help them and we are
pro-life we want to we are pro saving
these kids
they are so immediately uh able to just
just go blind whenever there's matt
gates or joel greenberg or donald trump
or any of these other people that are
involved in these parties that have had
involvement
and they go what nope never saw that
never saw that don't know what you're
talking about this is this is a this
this guy is a straight
white man who is an up
upright citizen he is uh totally not
ever doing anything wrong
but then you look back and you're like
oh no this guy's a [ __ ] creep
uh definitely 100 a creep but um
here is here is the um
here's the
image
that's going around this is cnn's camera
view yeah and it shows that it looks
more like a pink than a red but you know
right well in this one it looks pink
they really you know
did not do service to this the feed that
we had was beautiful yeah yeah you can
see the blue you can see the red yeah
this one is the colors are off on this
biden was lit properly it was it's
almost like the media wanted to be able
to slam this speech because i forget who
it is from cnn jeff some some dumb [ __ ]
ski or something he he said something
about these two marines in the
background like oh this is unprecedented
it is it is ridiculous that an american
president would have two marines
standing behind him during a speech i
don't understand all the time what what
is what is unprecedented about this i
have no idea the way like where they're
positioned i don't understand
i don't know well that the quote was
standing at attention i'll see if i can
find that [ __ ] but like
always standing at attention
i mean i can call up i can call up my
friend who's a marine and ask him
right but like it's one of those things
it's like aren't you always at attention
when you are on duty
it it really is weird that they're that
this is the thing they're pissed off
about
that there's two marines in the
background well because they have
nothing else to attack because if they
go against the speech
right you know other than like oh he's
in front of a red background and it's
very uh hitler kind of feel to it like
other than critiquing the the overall
aesthetic of it
they can't go against the speech which
was right
you do not have the like you do not have
the right to use violence as a political
tool to go against others we are at our
core a democracy and we will not let
fascism we will not let these crazy
people
go against what we believe in and that
is our constitution
and so
if you go against it i mean like he put
him in a corner and he's like look if
you go against this like law and order
will follow you
it will come after you [ __ ] around and
find out is literally what this speech
was right like dude i dare all of you
you can say whatever you want but as
soon as you take an action as soon as
you take a violent measure [ __ ] around
and find out
right well i mean i that that that's
been the actual
feeling in the country for a while now
for a couple months [ __ ] around and find
out now here is
this instance here because during the
speech if he didn't watch the speech
there was some [ __ ] bonehead with a
with a bullhorn and i'm not sure how far
away he was it seemed like he was pretty
far away but he was yelling and
screaming and heckling into a bullhorn
and the born has one of them alarm
things on it so he was yeah playing the
alarm and yelling and screaming to the
[ __ ] bullhorn he's a [ __ ] idiot
but this i think this was your favorite
part of the speech here um where biden
acknowledges them but totally wads them
up and dunks them in the trash here yeah
listen to this
is it screwing up for you two i don't
hear anything
yet see i'm telling you man my sound is
all jacked up over here i don't hear it
this is gonna be this is gonna be this
is not gonna work
for bonehead huh oh [ __ ]
i mean it just i restarted i
reprogrammed i tried to
make some adjustments it's not working
you played it nothing's working
huh yeah so here's what i'm going to do
here's what i'm going to do
you you stay on the show for a minute
talk to the folks here
i'm going to go out of the studio i'm
gonna try to uh reset everything all
right and then i'll come back in so
don't don't don't in the broadcast stay
right here i will i will stay here i
will stay here if you want you can go to
a break um let me let me take this down
because it's gonna it's gonna pull out
as soon as so so everybody it's the gabe
show hey
hey everyone
uh this is great you wanna share your
screen and maybe go to the [ __ ] let's
round up everyone i'll be right back i'm
gonna try to see if i can reset here
yeah yeah stick with gabe all uh
well anyway hey everyone how's your
friday going um
this is now the gabe sanchez show or the
gabe sanchez podcast welcome and i hope
you're all having a wonderful great
friday
um here let's see if i can share my
screen and get this party started he'll
be back in a second so don't you worry
for all you
tony michaels uh fans who think he looks
like kurt russell or uh leonardo
dicaprio he'll be back in a moment
i will share my screen
um but other than that how are you guys
doing i've oh i get a quick update i've
been working on a new video a jim
trustee
um
a gym trustee video
for a long commercial so
should be
should be pretty good i'm hoping to
finish that i was hoping i was actually
hoping to finish it before i got on the
show today
but let's uh let's get this party
started
all right so
let's go into as tony says the trendy
trends
um dictator oh well we can always
imagine what's gonna happen here we've
got them you know the right attacking
joe biden for giving a speech last night
that was pro-democracy and then we got
of course
the fact-checking that's happening here
which is the republicans that were
actually dictators the want to be
fascists the the people who say that
they're domestic terrorists uh you know
let's call it what it is you know um the
projection against biden is pretty funny
because
the right finds themselves in a position
where they feel like they're the victim
they feel like they're oppressed they
feel like they're the ones who have been
wronged but really it's
it's not they're the ones who are the
the actual predators they're the ones
who are actually attacking i mean look
at this right
calling
you know republicans are calling biden
pure evil satanic and a dictator because
he had blue and red back lane meanwhile
you've got people at cpac and other
other conventions that have
the uh nazi symbol red coloring like
this is you know also
complete violence as well
um let's check it out let's see what
else we got uh john stewart
uh boom boom oh look you're back
oh my god and it's we're talking about
perfect
what what what oh dictators you mean
orbon which one
no well it was saying and i said well
dictators trending which i imagine was
probably from the right and they're
right
criticized by my examples but
you've got people who literally say
we're domestic terrorists you've got
people who are you know
all all
red backlighting and also the ability of
wait wait wait you're saying you're
saying that anyone who stands in front
of a red background is now a dictator
and uh a nazi is that what you're saying
it would seem that way if you're in
front of a red screen this is what
they're saying if you're in front of a
red screen and you give a speech you're
a dictator not only that
but you're especially a dictator or a
fascist or just an overall nazi when you
have [ __ ] nazi symbols that your
stage is made from
oh or whatever you mean if you actually
have a nazi symbol for your stage and
and you put up on your your your big uh
billboard or your big uh
board and you say out loud we are all
domestic terrorists does that mean the
opposite does that mean they're not that
or what what does that mean
i don't know i mean like it's one of
those things where i think if you take
the argument of charlie kirk he goes
they call us all these names so you know
what we could say something that's worse
than fascist like you know they're just
going to i mean i'm rubber you're glue
well yeah but they're also going to be
like this is what you guys wanted us to
be you called as this so now we're going
to be it and it's like no you were those
things you were that thing you are that
vile disgusting
uh representation of humanity what
you're doing right now is you're using
us calling you out as an excuse
to validate your own existence and
behavior to be like well this is what
you guys wanted you guys wanted me to be
a nazi you guys want to be a via fashion
it's like no you're the one who wanted
to be it you just got called saying you
are that
we're just pointing out that you
absolutely are what what you are doing
right i mean it's really it's it's
really kind of [ __ ] dumb but i mean
they're dumb so what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do what else do we
have on the list here let's see
we have dictator this is vice president
christina kirchner's head okay uh jon
stewart japan is back army hammer oh man
that's
class classified is trending i wonder
what that could be
crazy i would guess
so there's the ap report on um
on this this new inventory you know the
other thing i noticed in the inventory
and we're probably going to get into it
in bonehead in here in just a minute
yeah um but the other thing i notice in
the inventory
is
that there's like
dozens and dozens of government
government pictures is how they market
right and you know and i i said this
earlier you know it is a picture all of
them every one of them is a picture of
him standing in front of some duck oh
yeah
with some dumb person giving that dumb
thumbs up like the every picture is is
him it looks like a cardboard cut out of
him oh i guarantee you i mean remember
well in in in the uh more detailed you
know unsealed inventory list like it
says between this year and this year
it's magazine articles right and this
year and this year it's between magazine
articles which is interesting that they
they broke them up into two different
year groups can you find can you find
the uh we're we're on opposite sides
look at that oh does the audience like
how we're backwards oh boy which way do
you guys want you want to like
oh oh you switch at the same time
okay now i feel better now i know better
we're on the correct side you sound
correct now but he if you want to find
that photo that we had yesterday not the
one last night but the one yesterday
that that we showed that had like stacks
of magazines it had like numbers on
if we can find that one because i want
to point out because
like that's one of the itemized things
in here is just like magazines and
newspapers and [ __ ] and and here's the
thing that [ __ ] was cleaning off
his desk somewhere right that's what
that [ __ ] is
he's got all this [ __ ] stacked on his
desk and he's piling it up here is that
let's um here we're gonna have to um
remember
let me see if i can this see we're just
all backwards this is on the fly this is
what happens when you do it live we'll
do it do it live
do live do it live we should we should
we should definitely uh
have that clip on the ready just
whenever something just that like yeah
when we hang out whenever it goes wrong
so here it goes right here's right
here's the here's the picture we showed
yesterday and i'm not sure who he's
sitting here with i don't know who this
she probably is probably i don't know
maybe some other criminal some other
criminal i don't know um but it might be
who he's interviewing for this article
that could be
because it was for it was for a
uh
it was an article that was written in
2017 that was titled from fast company
what trump's messy office reveals about
his leadership style so it's actually
about this [ __ ] hardy mess yeah and
the sub the the sub headline here is a
neuroscientist finds several troubling
clues well i mean does it you don't have
to be a [ __ ] scientist yeah you have
to be a brain surgeon or neuroscientist
and know that i mean so here it is you
got newspaper articles here you got
[ __ ] books here and that's another
thing there was actual books yeah i was
like whoa he he actually had books he
was like oh i want this book but it's
probably because he's on the cover or
he's like in the forward or something
right and it was on his desk because he
had it as bragging and he hasn't no he
and i also want to say whatever forward
that was written for a book that he was
given that he was asked to write about
or whatever has not read
no no no page just has it there and be
like oh did he didn't even write the
forward oh yeah not at all i mean he
probably copied it or whatever but as
soon as somebody brings it or comes in
the office hey do you see that did you
read that book yet and they're like oh
no i didn't say i wrote the forward and
it's like no you [ __ ] you know all
right right
well
the other thing on that list is there's
a piece of clothing somewhere on that
list see if you can find the the um if
you can find an image of
the um
the list where it shows a piece of
clothing because i almost bet it's a
[ __ ] maga hat
because it says like clothing or
merchandise or some [ __ ] you know you
know that it's a [ __ ] maga hat which
one is this
the
the the list the list of inventory there
is oh oh oh oh god piece of clothing now
i thought maybe it was melania's closet
you know a piece right right
when they were digging through the
underwear drawer one piece of you know
clothing
negligee got uh stuffed into the box or
something
some panties some panties yeah when they
were doing the panty raid as fox knew so
well put it but no i actually it's a
manga hat for sure it's a hundred
percent of my right so if i look through
right now documents documents
photographs there's one that says piece
of clothing okay i promise piece of
clothing piece of clothing article of
clothing slash right gift item that's it
that's it it's either it's and one but
one book one book
it's either a maga hat or one of them
stupid trump capes oh probably it's it's
one of those two things or it could be
one of them oh that big ass foam hat but
there's also more and more what more
there's books uh there's three artists
so hold on let me let me go back can i
read this right well you know because
there's different things and i'll put
bring it up on the screen right sorry
link send me a link and i'll bring up on
the screen and then we'll go through
this and then we'll do bonehead of the
week now that we're
i can um
trust that i can
produce it trust
maybe we need to call jim trustee oh
really
sounds like someone um just gotta i'm
working on it i'm almost done i'm
working on the background here okay so
let's see here so we've got um
there's this is this is the one with the
43 empty folders that everyone's been
concentrated on
like right here okay and then
um these are some of these are boxes and
this says item number two now this is
important
because item number two is the two on
two a
right
am i wrong item number two right that's
and then hey so because if you look
they show this had [ __ ] two
confidential documents 15 secret
documents seven top secret documents 69
get your mind out of the gutter i wasn't
even going there i wasn't going there i
wasn't even going there and you took it
there and now my mind is there 69 us
government documents slash photographs
without classified classification
markings which is probably him with this
thumbs up that's what i'm saying
43 empty folders with classified banners
and then 28 empty folders labeled return
to staff
you know what do the math here what is
43
71 71 and then how many
how many
there's way okay there's way more
[ __ ] folders here than there are
documents do you see that yes like you
could say oh he was taking the documents
out of the folders and then like having
a stack of folders and a stack of
documents yeah that makes no sense but
well he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] does this guy
do anything that makes sense the whole
day and the whole day he's like he's
like oh [ __ ] he goes i'm the president
and then he just takes the stuff he
takes the documents out of the folder
goes one document two document three
document close folder
one document and then two documents he
takes the byte of the yeah and he goes
and then he waves his hand over he's
declassified
he goes he goes through maybe like a
couple folders and he goes i'm tired
and then he just walks away and he's
like i need my nap
do you think do you think it's like when
he waves his hands he does like the
wayne's world
horizontal yeah he's very well could
yeah i mean i do i do think there's like
a there's a sharpie involved like it's a
wand oh so the sharpie is like the magic
wand okay yeah yeah it looks like harry
potter let's move on here if yeah if you
go down and then so in this one box
number eight there is one article of
clothing and a gift item and a splash
gift item and a book then you go to the
next document let me see if i can
do
this one here uh-huh then you go up to
in i think and then box number nine that
has another how many articles of
clothing i can't read that yeah i know i
get one because you're zoomed in that's
why yeah
oh no it's actually on the screenshot
that's why
never mind so so it's hidden so it's
yeah so it's another article of clothing
gift item and then you go to box number
uh well 10
and there's three articles of clothing
gift items and another book
so do you think he's got like he's he's
because you know they keep saying oh
well he he wants trinkets and and and
mementos yeah do you think that that's
what this [ __ ] is is this is old manga
hats and probably he goes that's the
first edition that's the second edition
that's the third he goes all made in
china
oh my god but yeah he's got more each
box has like an article of clothing or a
book with it or could you have guessed
that this list that they released this
morning would damage trump's case and
damaged the the the actual arguments
that they could you guess that that's
what it would do there's no way you
could have guessed that when they
released the inventory list that it was
going to destroy the arguments that they
already had it's
it is something that i
i you know i didn't i did not know what
to expect out of this inventory list
right i didn't know to the extent also
of like how unsealed or sealed it was
gonna be
um well and we we knew it was gonna be a
little more detailed than than right
right it was already unredacted right
right right
yeah so i don't yeah so like even in
this like okay it's not you know it's
not revealing any
sensitive information
it is giving us an idea to be like oh
wow okay he had a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ]
over there right various things you know
mixed in
various parts of the the compound that
is mar-a-lago
but like i said earlier you know i could
very well see the argument going to well
it's he just had folders there's nothing
wrong with folders right and it's like
why does he have so many [ __ ] empty
folders then like is he a hoarder like
why is he collecting the stuff weren't
there documents in between and if nara
and this and and the our government is
saying
these documents are missing
and there was only one printed copy or
two printed copies whatever we can we
can account for the other ones
and one of them is missing
and the last person to have it and
you've got the [ __ ] folders where are
the documents right well that's right
because it can't be two things at once
right he either took empty folders which
is kind of weird which makes him look i
think it makes him look dumb right it
makes them look dumber but so you either
took empty folders or the [ __ ] left the
folders one or the other there's no i
mean why they left the folders is more
questions but it's not it can't be both
things yeah you cannot yeah you cannot
have it in both in both sides
you know what i'll say yeah is i think
he's he's got a lot of lawyers here and
actually three of them appeared on the
bone end of the week which we're going
to get into here in just a second
but i think more than he needs a lawyer
he's gonna need he's gonna need a really
he's gonna need a lot of pardons
he's gonna need a lot of pardons here oh
my god the guy is
up a [ __ ] creek without a paddle so
let's do this let's go to the break when
we come back we'll have bonehead of the
week when we come back stick around bone
of the week right when we come back
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa don't delay and
get your part in blanket today for just
99.99
actual parting's not guaranteed
back into it this is the tony michaels
podcast
welcome back to the show
it's friday
second hour you know what that means
bone end of the week
you vote you decide we break it down in
the second hour every single friday
[Music]
we finally got our technical issues
technical difficulties
taken care of so now
we go to
bonehead of the week
oh and then yeah see i'm still i'm it's
it's it's just it's a it's a hard day
today i don't know why
i don't know what it is i don't know
what it is here we are
the week
bonehead of the week we made it
it's been a [ __ ] week man holy [ __ ]
dude there's just in the last two days
there's been enough news to pack in a
month yeah it's like six years worth of
news in every goddamn day like
10 pounds of [ __ ] in a two-pound bag
it's crazy ketchup is hitting the fan
everywhere at mar-a-lago the news does
not stop
and neither do we did is he is he um
posting
about on uh
on truth social yeah on on my social
media
i just thought about nope
doesn't look like it no no the last
thing he he uh he truthed he reached
the god that sounds so [ __ ] so dumb
why did they he's like hey we want to
copy twitter and we're going to now turn
truth into a verb that
isn't the way it was intended to be so
truths truths and replies re-truths it
sounds stupid i mean
what is better what's even better is the
[ __ ] didn't even check on
trademarks before they did that i know
they didn't even check on it they were
like can we even trademark this
they're like truth sounds
sounds good to me and then they just
went with it and then other people who
were in the social
marketing social media space were like
because here's the thing you don't even
have to have a trademark
to have ownership of it but if you've
been in a space long enough to establish
yourself right because that entity
because that kind of gives you the
trademark right like yeah yeah like i
mean
the obvious to get a trademark you have
to actually have that like in public
right right right right yeah so if
anybody asked like oh yeah i applied for
it and i was approved for the trademark
however if you're in that space long
enough i i don't know if there's a
period of time they have to pass but i
do know that if you're in there for a
period of time then it's like de facto
okay this group has been here everyone
associates that name
with that
that type of industry or whatever that
is because the other thing too is when
you have a trademark right
or you have a name of a company and
you're in the same sector industry it
causes confusion
so you can't have multiple companies or
more than one company that has that
especially when that's your main name
and you have other existing names in the
social media space which they're already
two i think at the time
so there's already two that are called
true social already well they have truth
in the name it's not called true social
but it's the fact that they're in the
social media space wow in the sector and
they have truth as a part of their main
name and they didn't they couldn't
google that or duck that go that before
they [ __ ] decided oh no you totally
could there's a whole thing you could
like if you're like hey i want to make a
trademark for xyz whatever
you can go to the actual trademark the
u.s government trademark registration
site and you can look it up you can just
type in a search and be like truth and
they'll tell you it'll tell you
everything
both active and inactive trademarks for
the word truth well here's what they
could have done it easily could have
done it no problem here's what it sounds
like he not only does he need good
criminal alternatives he needs a better
trademark attorney let's get into
bonehead of the week uh here we go let's
let's start the music
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this week's bonut of the week
this edition it has a theme this week it
is um the lackey trump attorneys is the
theme of the bonehead
poll this week
gabe he's got a lot of um really stupid
attorneys these television these
television attorneys is what they really
seem like now let's look at the
candidates here we have uh christina bob
as we know it's not just not just his
television attorney she's also
um an old host on oan propaganda on oan
but more importantly she was in the
department of homeland security and
and she helped john eastman write the
cheeto dust kangaroo coup plan she's one
of the architects and was in the war
room with that trader steve bannon uh
rudy kaluti
rudy giuliani and also john eastman
himself uh jim trustee here
this guy has made an appearance here
all of a sudden um i don't even know who
this guy is but uh we're gonna find out
and then alina is it alina ahab a habba
is that how you say yeah alina habba
alina habba there um our bonehead of the
week uh contestants here
and you guys voted and it was
overwhelmingly um which one was the
bonehead of the week and really honestly
i think the issue is
is that we really didn't get to see what
trustee you know we didn't get to see
his bone-headedness marinate enough yeah
i mean he was you know he's a he's a
he's a late comer right right he was a
late entertainer
what a a late comer okay i got you
what dude get your mind out of the
gutter i i'm just making sure what you
said yeah all right all right i'm trying
to do uh he he is uh he is late to enter
the race yeah okay gotcha into the legal
race which is trump's uh incompetent
uh
just
because watch these
every time they go on they have the
dumbest takes again we're not lawyers i
mean we you know we'll we'll chat you
know we'll chime in with ben every now
and again when these new takes come out
and he's like this is so dumb right this
is the most exciting thing i've ever
heard sometimes that's what we do is
like before we go on a show or make a
video where it's like hey we kind of
need to know what the
what it actually is or isn't yeah we'll
either go on and we'll we'll figure out
if harry lipman or or popock or
or or glenn or someone's gonna give like
some sort of explanation we'll go we'll
even go to uh allison with mueller she
wrote we're trying to find someone
who has some [ __ ] common sense and
sometimes we go to ben mizellis and
we're like hey
we need a quick answer on this we're
going to make a video some we're going
to say something we want to make sure
we're not [ __ ] saying some dumb [ __ ]
like these stupid [ __ ] tv lawyers
yeah so we'll ask him a quick question
and he'll respond back like nope it's
exactly what you think they're [ __ ]
dumb like yeah why not so many words
that's mine right right and it's also
like one of those things like you know
when we've we've been in you know
texting with him about these
these motions that they've been
submitting right and even then he's like
this is
a hot mess man it doesn't make any sense
what talking about arbitrary legal
theory what's funny when you watch ben
on like legal af or some of his like
breaking takes and he's he's
flabbergasted in those videos that is
actually that's authentic yeah he is he
actually he's like this like last night
there was that same type of like what
are we doing
when we were doing the actual live
stream yesterday of biden speech like we
were talking about mar-a-lago and these
these documents and these motions and he
was just like
ah this is as a lawyer it this hurts my
head right because this is not the way
it's supposed to go it's all backwards
and confused and the reason why is
because we're dealing with trump here
that's the reason why but all of you new
listeners out there you have you have
entered the bonehead of the week segment
here on the tony michael's podcast what
happens we air every single weekday
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
and twitch so go follow our youtube
channel at tony michael's podcast don't
forget to subscribe over there you can
watch every single show every single
weekday but bone end of the week
we put up a poll on twitter at
tonymichaelspot so follow us over there
you get to vote every single week
for bone end of the week of the
contestants that we put up and this week
we have all of trump's bone-headed
attorneys here yeah that's not even all
of them because there was a new there
was a new one that was released uh or
that was that was brought off the bench
right recently just on tuesday he's a
newcomer he's a newcomer canoe comer
he's or would i say a late comer late
comer yeah yeah late that's why i was
like late comer come on yeah
what is all this well you know what's
funny
i wanted to bring this up last night but
we were on the midas touch podcast yeah
and i feel like we can get away with
more [ __ ] over here on the tony
michael's podcast and bone into the week
than they can right there
i cuz
they keep talking about a special master
right and then and then the special
master with the fbi they're a taint team
it just yeah it's i it man i don't know
what kind of gutter these attorneys
minds are in and these judges and people
who are making these names up but
special master taint team and now you're
saying late comer this is all this is
all getting very
it is very saucy very fast yeah and i
mean they're at a certain point they're
just they're like look uh
these normal names aren't cutting it we
need something that everyone's gonna
remember right you know exactly exactly
so if you want to watch bone end of the
week watch it every single friday in the
second hour of the tony michaels podcast
or you can watch the replay right here
in prime time on the midas touch network
so don't forget to subscribe if you're
on the midas touch network channel to
subscribe now you can also
start with trustee downl think we should
start with trustee yeah we give we'll
give you his moment um because i saw an
ad you know um out there for trustee
that seemed to be
you know he's kind of he's kind of cheap
he's not that expensive yeah yeah
maybe that's the reason why he went with
trump went with him is because
well he's he saw him on uh he saw him on
tv and it was like that's the guy i need
right because that's literally how he
found him he saw him on fox news uh
because i haven't seen i haven't seen
him actually on any other network so i
would imagine it was fox news but only
fox news that is how
he hired jim trustee and this is this is
one of the pictures from fox news that
appears
um because you you tweeted here meet jim
trusty one of the lawyers trump's hired
after seeing him on tv
and um it appears here that you can hire
jim trustee for
184 easy payments
of
99.99
www trust me i'm jimtrusty.com
is this really his [ __ ] phone number
no no no that's not his actual i just
put that there but what i can say is
that i am uh i'm working i actually you
know what i'll play the video we'll play
the video do you want to play it put it
in that put it in yeah yeah yeah
okay but but this is this is an uh this
will be an updated uh
uh it's tr it's uh jimtrusty.com is the
updated uh url that we're gonna use
because i'm working with toby morgan oh
that's right after this happened he was
like oh i'm gonna buy the domain and so
then we've been chatting about it i see
um i see but but uh the jim trustee
thread here um let's see put that video
up and we'll play it but um
uh here is here is actually an interview
here where he's talking about a special
master on fox news with i don't know who
this is but let's let's listen to the
traders talk pieces one in the wall
street journal over the weekend that
talks about the high bar and the huge
challenge another one of the new york
times
that merrick garland uh has right now he
basically has two different cases this
raid at mar-a-lago and also the january
6 issue
under which he could potentially
prosecute a former president of the
united states okay so right there like
you're laying it out yes there is a h
high bar for criminality that is true
and yes merrick garland has two
opportunities so far
to prosecute at that eye bar for
criminality
and we're starting to see the evidence
because of trump and his legal team roll
out right in front of our eyes
of what they're going to prosecute them
for and why they're going to like this
is not normal and that's what ben was
trying to say last night too like this
is not back in normal normally what a
defendant does is like oh [ __ ] i'm in
trouble i need to batten down the
hatches i need to not say a thing and
let my legal team handle this [ __ ] yeah
because if they would had a decent legal
team well cause also it's the things
that he's saying right if he's going on
these programs he's releasing these
statements on truth social he's you know
going to giving a speech somewhere
these are things that can and probably
will be used against him to say you had
intent clearly you're indicating that
you knew you had the documents right
these are all things that can go against
him and i'm very surprised that his
legal team isn't like yo
shut the hell up dude stop talking his
legal team can't shut the hell up oh
yeah so let's listen to jim trustee here
and see what
see what this guy has to say
so one of the things that's broken down
in here is the parallel that was created
by jim comey when he did a similar
investigation of information and
confidential documents that hillary
clinton kept on a private server okay if
it is the same
if there is a parallel here
what
could it have been that the moglodites
were saying about the hillary clinton
emails what could it possibly have been
i think there was a three letter or
three word chant that they were chanting
at rallies i can't remember exactly what
it was
i can't remember exactly what they were
calling for but you know there's
something there
and he came out at the time and said
that you know a they had held back
documents the clinton team they held
back documents after they said oh we
gave them all the classified information
um but yet they couldn't prosecute so
tell me what your take is on on what is
different or the same in those two
things and did that set a precedent for
handling this case that cannot be
overturned okay so before dumbfox speaks
here yeah
they're not the same it is not the same
it's not the same at all
she didn't steal any documents she
didn't take anything that didn't belong
to her the government wasn't asking her
to give something back that she took
that they needed
and when they did when they did request
the server she didn't have to have the
[ __ ] fbi come and get it they they
got the server went and they actually
gave it to them well she yeah they were
like look you can you can come on in you
can just take it you can get it right as
opposed to
we don't have it we don't know what
you're talking about and they're like
well we're pretty sure we know it's
missing and we tracked it down and we're
almost positive you have it somewhere
and probably have it here and he's like
no no we don't have it if we had it we
would have told you if we had it we
would have given it back to you and
they're like okay okay okay fine we have
it here is some of it and they're like
okay thanks and they take it back and
they're like oh well this isn't actually
all of it where's the rest of it like we
don't have it what are you guys talking
about like no we know you have it
they're like okay fine here's the rest
of it and again they're like
okay they're like [ __ ] it we're just
gonna come down and get it ourselves
right
clearly this whole like asking you for
it and you telling you gave it to us
isn't working out right well let's
listen to trustee here i'm sure we can
trust everything that comes out of his
pie hole here
well it may not have been the most
respectful precedent in terms of the way
it was rolled out by jim comey and the
reasoning that he employed but but i'll
take it in terms of the result and look
the the difference was incredibly there
was a striking difference between the
two situations hillary clinton had no
protection under the presidential
records act that had nothing to do with
her at all why did they keep quoting the
presidential records act like he like it
some kind of right he has is not opposed
to the law he [ __ ] broke what why do
they keep doing this not only that but
the law he broke and the law that he
made even more strict right before he
left right he was like yeah yeah this
this actually like two years you're
making a felony yeah yeah we're gonna go
five years yeah
i don't understand why they keep
referring to it as if he it's like they
if they're like he has the right to
these because he was the that's not what
that thing says at all like it doesn't
say it's not even close he cannot take
it
and just go he's like
i'm gonna take this to go okay like he's
making some sort of order at a
restaurant like do you want it for here
at the white house or do you want to go
at margo mar-a-lago i mean it's like
he's driving through yeah it's like he's
driving through it's right for fast food
yeah he's like oh i'm gonna i'm gonna
pick it up to go and they're like that's
not how that works you can't just take
government documents and then go all
right got it see you guys later and no
you you just can't do that that's not
how you they weren't declassified i've
been asking this question if you're
going to eat because we know these
documents have left these folders if
you're going to eat
a classified document is it
do you put on a regular bun a sesame
seed bun what kind of bun do you oh no
bun no no bun no oh so it's just no no i
think there's i think there's several
ways you can eat so it's a low carb it's
a low carb it's a low it's a low carb
diet you put some ketchup on it you know
you know maybe some sophie or something
and you just you can roll it long or you
can take it you know sideways like a
wrap yeah you can make it a wrap you can
make it a hot dog you can make it a
hamburger depending on the shape you
want but yeah you're making me hungry
geez okay
you can even make it into a taco i guess
classified taco
let's listen to dummy here
in terms of how you actually classify
these documents as only presidential or
personal the classification doesn't
matter she had a personal server that is
a
tremendously more uh insecure way of
having access that's why it's different
that's why it's different that's why
that's why james comey actually cascaded
hillary clinton he said it was
irresponsible for her to do that because
she had government information on a
private server it would almost be like
if she stole
digital documents yeah from the
government server and put it on her
server then can you imagine if that was
the case if she would have stole them as
she's walking out the door as secretary
of state she swiped a bunch of [ __ ]
government documents classified top
secret documents and then took them home
on a thumb drive and put them on her
computer oh i can i can just tell you
yeah the outrage the outrage if we got
you know that the same level probably if
they probably get more actually based on
the
the history of of republicans getting
mad at a tan suit and getting mad at
emails and it's just one of those things
where it's like as you accelerate based
on the controversies that are there
they're going to make a big deal out of
something that is not from their own
party right so when it comes to these
documents which contain human
intelligence information they contain uh
data or information that should only be
read in a skiff they have information
relating to
nuclear secrets they just go
guys guys what it's it's his stuff it's
his stuff why is it president
presidential record zach
why why are we making such a big deal
about this right i mean you had greg
gutfeld on on the five the other day
laughing
about
how this was all like oh you're trying
to relate this to this it's like he's
he's trying to belittle the fact that
our former president stole lied and hid
government top secret highly classified
documents and they're like yeah it's no
big deal it's like whatever well i mean
you know here's the thing is i really
think joe biden should take just
truckloads of top secret documents when
he leaves take take him over to delaware
why not yeah i mean apparently the
presidential record act lets you take
anything you want [ __ ] he should take
the [ __ ] furniture out of the white
house well not only that but as a as a
president if you have you know they're
saying oh you can unilaterally just like
wave a hand and say it's declassified
well if trump did that then biden could
also in this same moment say do that
classified right and then he gets to be
like you can't have these these are
classified so it's the same type of
[ __ ] when when they try to make an
argument like oh well we should we
should impeach this person okay well the
next person up is is harris okay well
the next person up is pelosi like they
don't think these three these things
through and so when they make an
argument that is of a like illegal
status or stature they go well this is
what this is what it is and it's like
okay well let's really think this one
through
because if you're saying that this is
true then the other president or the
current president biden could also act
the same way right with the documents
that he declines the same way that
you're saying well it reminds me of that
you remember that when they when the
gasoline was going up because russia
invaded a sovereign country you mean
because biden hit the switch on his desk
right yeah and they they put we're
putting stickers i did that on the gas
pumps pointing to the price and now as
the price is going down the sticker's
still there saying i did that like they
didn't have the foresight to go
and eventually to go down like it was
only only gasoline only goes up it never
goes down same thing with the let's go
brandon you know you co-op the message
and you say actually we're going to use
that for this and now they're really
upset at the dark branding thing right
because they do not have the foresight
they do not future proof their dumb ass
ideas so when [ __ ] turns the other way
against them and for the democratic
party they're like oh [ __ ]
oh no no no and they're rushing all over
the place and trying to trying to peel
the stickers off the gas pumps but that
that's why that's why
yes this morning they're freaking out
because joe biden is rallying democracy
to defeat them and they're freaking the
[ __ ] out now you found a speaking of
this jim is it jim trustee is that what
he's doing
james james trustee is his full name but
he goes by jim jim jimmy
jimmy trusty here you found the draft
version of a commercial that he did is
that right yeah i found on the the deep
dark brandon webb okay well let's
let's let's play this draft version of
the commercial that he's gonna air soon
is your patriotic voice being cancelled
did you try to overthrow the government
are you a former president who stole
highly classified documents well then
you need a lawyer you can trust
hi i'm jim trusted and i'm a lawyer
really when i was charged with smearing
my own [ __ ] on the walls of the capitol
on january 6th jim was there to defend
me and thanks to him i only got to serve
16 months in prison i also teach
criminal courtroom evidence and trial
advocacy at the university of maryland
when i took jim trustee's course i
learned that stealing government
property was like as serious as like an
overdue library book oh and i almost
forgot now you can follow me on twitter
for unsolicited legal takes so when you
need a lawyer you can trust remember to
call jim trustee for just 184 easy
payments of
99.99 will maybe help you too no money
back guarantee
oh i changed his website and his phone
number but uh yeah it looks like he's
getting i'm not saying that's his real
phone number oh but but that's his real
phone number
well i mean he put it out there he he
put it he's advertising it he's
advertising it we're just trying to make
sure i'm just saying show you the facts
he actually and
i don't know if you can hear it but i
said you know you would normally say i
taught this class
but on the university of maryland
website for where he is a professor yep
he is a professor
what he does
or what they did was they wrote
he teached
no they didn't he did yeah i'll find him
right now he teaches
these classes so i tried to repeat it
but i don't know if i came across when i
was doing the and i was like stuff in my
face that by the way that was you no i
thought that was jim just
jim trustee who else do we got on the
list we had we got christina bob on the
list
christina bob we've we've ran into
christina bob a lot here at the tony
michaels podcast over the last year
because we know who christina bob is
she's not fooling us she's not fooling
us here at the johnny michael's podcast
she was in the war room
um with
with
john eastman
rudy giuliani steve bannon trying to
overthrow our government now let me show
you a picture of that here
here it is here um this is uh again you
see john eastman here you see rudy
kaluti uh grandpa farty mcsharty rudy
giuliani and then christina bob right
here everyone wants to make her have to
be an oan propagandist which she is that
she is there she is yeah but she was in
the department of homeland security she
was an executive secretary
now she's never really been an attorney
until she had to be one for trump
obviously because some of the bones did
that [ __ ] she said is there something
specific bone hinted that she that she
said this week that we want to that we
want to play
i'm trying to recall i i'm i'm honestly
doing a catalog in my brain right now of
all the dumb things that they've said
uh
i stuff well we definitely have one for
uh alina habba
right yeah i'm trying to think if
christina i mean like a shitty legal
dick yeah
[Laughter]
well here you go
um
it's the christina bob that uh
actually um this is what started it off
that was the original video that this
one here
the yeah the one with the pink in front
of it was like is she in front of a
green screen kind of situation yeah yeah
she's trying jupiter but that one's on
jupiter yeah yeah that was she's she's
definitely on another planet
uh
that is
[ __ ] so in this one this is when it all
really started right this is where it's
so this is her justification of him
stealing top secret documents this is
this is the uh the original it might
have been planted [ __ ] i think yeah uh i
i don't think that there was actually
anything there that's worthwhile i will
see what they come up with you know if
they did it'll be interesting especially
since they precluded me from actually
watching what they did
but but at this point i don't
necessarily think that they would even
go to the extent of trying to plant
information i think they just make stuff
up
and you know come up with whatever they
want and i that's the way that they will
have to proceed in order to actually try
to indict the president because
they don't have anything there's just
nothing there
oh boy this one this one was evergreen
wasn't it gabe
oh my god i mean the [ __ ] buffoonery
the bonehead injury here is just
astounding this again this is back when
when they originally
served
yeah this was august 9th so the day
after is when she
it's him that's goddamn long
holy
man like dude i've been trying to work
on a honestly i've been trying to work
on a what was that segment for this and
i'm like oh maybe i should wait till
this and now that this inventory list
has come out i'm like okay maybe i can
finally make one
it honestly might be the longest segment
it won't be a half hour but it might be
like maybe 10 12 15 minutes
it's gonna be long especially with all
these clips of these dumb [ __ ] in here
i know christina bomb this this is the
most evergreen clip
it aged so beautifully
in the matter and in a matter of three
weeks it went from like uh that's a
that's a dumb take to oh man that is the
dumbest of takes
well what's what's even better is the
other attorney that we have on the
bonehead list yeah she's like oh all
kinds of people are in and out of this
spot like all
christina bobbie is trying to make the
argument that there was nothing there
there's no way they'll find anything
yeah there's no way and of course they
found all kinds of [ __ ] we have the list
one of those things that they keep
talking they keep saying stuff and they
keep going no no no it's not as bad as
it looks it's this is they planted it uh
it wasn't serious this this and that
like they're coming up with all these
you know bone-headed answers and and and
responses and takes and then the doj
goes okay look we didn't even want to
make this thing public
but because you guys keep saying [ __ ]
we have to respond and every time we
respond we show a little bit more like
we we allow you to peek behind the
curtain with with information that is
that can be actually shared and doesn't
actually reveal certain like sensitive
information so every time they do that
republicans maga trump his lawyers they
all look like [ __ ] dumbasses they've
got egg on their face
and they keep smiling
and trying to work through it right well
here's one white house attorney who used
to be in trump's realm
who has
definitely exited but this attorney i
feel like he's sending this message not
to just john eastman but all these
attorneys that are on tv let's listen
to hershman here
oh it's it's not oh it doesn't have the
sound it's a gift get get get the
greatest criminal defense attorney
you're gonna [ __ ] need it that's what
he said i thought it was a i thought it
was a video
he [ __ ] tricked me oh man like later
too good dude
they tricked you they [ __ ] me they
[ __ ] me hard oh you bastards oh here
here here maybe this one maybe that's
when i have it uh here's another one
of the transition
i said good job now i'm going to give
you the best free legal advice you're
ever getting in your life
get a great fn criminal defense lawyer
you're going to need it get a great
criminal effing defense attorney you're
going to need it
oh my god wise wise advice for anyone
who is associated with trump
right just in the same room as him yeah
yeah
if you're even describing this like like
all these people who went in that room
who took pictures in that room who who
publicly posted them
i bet the fbi is going down that list to
try to figure out if those people saw
that [ __ ] yeah they were within [ __ ]
arm distance of top secret information
and i pointed this out the other day
that kyle rittenhouse was in that room
yeah and i know a lot of people like
what's in significance of that listen if
he was willing to let kyle rittenhouse
put his scumming little murderous hands
on these [ __ ] documents that are our
documents that are the highest
secrets in our government you don't
think you'd sell them to the saudis yeah
you don't think you just [ __ ] give
him away to russia for whatever the hell
he wants you don't think he would do
that unload a classified folder full of
top secret information i don't know that
could i don't know how much how many
folders it will hold two billion dollars
worth of classified documents we should
ask jared maybe but i'm just telling you
but trump i mean the the other thing too
that that we need to really acknowledge
is the fact that trump is an egomaniac
he he is a narcissist he thrives on
people complimenting him and doing what
he says and and being the the smartest
person in the room
so when he has guests in there
what does he have to offer because
there's nothing really more than like oh
i was president for four years and you
love me and oh this is great thumbs up
now the cherry on top would be he goes
hey check this [ __ ] out i've got these
documents that no one else has and
nobody knows that i have them and
they're like
100 percent that's what we do know we do
know the government does know that you
have them and they're coming for your
ass but the idea that he would go around
people and be like yeah you're gonna
want to check this document out let me
just go into my [ __ ] desk drawer
and open it up well that's why he got
the dishonorable mention or no he got
alpha cuck this week yeah he got out he
got he got alpha guy
because every
every time he tries to challenge the doj
they put him in the [ __ ] corner and
they're like you want to watch fine
[ __ ] make sure your eyes are open
while we do this like we will [ __ ]
and you watch
well i think we should play the uh tape
here where he um
he projects we played this the other day
but this is this is he's he's phoning it
in he continues the phone he literally
is phoning in it right he's literally
phoning in his confession here um i'm
i'm not kidding he's confessing to a lot
of [ __ ] here in this just i mean it's 42
seconds and he
he admits to like three federal crimes
here on this 43 seconds it's insanity
but let's listen to the um
the the alpha get cucked here and let's
listen a lot of people think that when
you walk into my office i have
confidential documents or whatever it
may be old you do you did until they
came and got this [ __ ] a lot of people a
lot of people think yeah a lot of people
do think that now right like you
you you you saw this thing right you
caused the doj to release this [ __ ] and
unseal it and they said
okay fine yeah i mean really he was the
one that got the doj involved in the
first place all he had to do was take
the [ __ ] little bit of slack that
nara was giving him on these classified
documents when they're like hey we need
our [ __ ] this stuff is highly sensitive
you cannot have this stuff yeah this is
not stuff you can have not only is it
not yours you are not allowed to have
this [ __ ] yeah we they warned them
let's listen classified but i had
confidential documents spread out all
over my far floor yeah you sure did you
sure did you were upset at the fact that
they made it look sloppy which by the
way is the standard way in which you
photograph a [ __ ] crime scene they
laid it out in an area that was
available to them and they took a photo
with the ruler and the evidence marker
and said great cool in the frame this
gives you an idea of what was stashed in
that box with those time magazine frame
covers right because and that's that's
why that box is sitting there because
that's the [ __ ]
box that's the box that it was in it's
really ridiculous okay let's let's
continue let's hear some more confession
here because he doesn't stop he doesn't
stop it saying i had classified
documents in my office because he said
some people are saying and then he
admits to it then he admits to it no
what
what
jesus christ this [ __ ] guy
and uh like a slob
like i'm sitting there reading these
documents all day long or somebody else
reading
the guy can't read do you hear the
background there's someone laughing in
the background of this audio they're
like
you can't
that's what i'm thinking like when
they're laughing when he says like i'm
sitting there reading doctors in their
lap like you can't you can't [ __ ]
read that's funny he's like he's like oh
dude yeah he's like oh they're laughing
at my joke and they're like no you are
the joke well i mean when he says i'm
just sitting around looking at these
documents it's exactly what you're
saying he has this [ __ ] stash in his
office the [ __ ] that he wants to show
people
is the [ __ ] that was in his office
and he knows where it's at and he's got
three of them in his destroy that are
ready and available to brad to have
bragging rights that he has top secret
information
let's continue
it's so it's so dishonest
when you look at it and so people were
so he says he's all those things are
telling you all that stuff is true yeah
it's all true but it's so dishonest it's
so dishonest that they made me look like
a slob yeah i i committed treason and
violated the espionage act and i took
those documents without permission and
there wasn't any log of these documents
there wasn't any communication with the
the agencies that actually classified
them so that they could declassify them
like there's no paper trail he just took
it and said mine and then now he's
saying well i declassified them and
people think i'm just looking at them
yeah you probably are you probably do
look at that [ __ ] every day to be like
i'm the president like that's the type
of mindset he has where he's like
today's classified folder will be the
bombing of xyz right like it'll be
something and then that's with the
things that he's like oh you want to
check out this this cool classified file
i've got
we're only 23 seconds into this
buffooners can you imagine listen to
this entire interview let's listen to
the last few tens of seconds we're
concerned because they said gee
you know that's a strange scene you look
at the floor and you see documents right
they have cover sheets of documents no
they put them there john and they put
them there in a messy fashion and then
they took a picture
and they released it to the public and
this is what we're dealing with with
these people do you remember the uh the
the documentary interview where he's
like i look orange i look like why did
he like comment why are you orange why
do i look can we fix that
why do i look horn this is the same [ __ ]
this is what i mean here's here's my
question is they're so upset they're
like oh he made it look sloppy and they
put it on the ground this and that like
i don't know what the actual layout of
his office is because we only see the
photos where he takes with people and he
gives the [ __ ] dumbass
thumbs up right right
but one of the kim jones yeah in front
of the i'm shaking kim jong-un's hand
and all this stuff
but when you
stop and really think about this
would he
would he have been like okay or like
happier if they had like neatly stacked
them right in like three rows a four
column like is that what he had been
okay with
would republicans not be outraged if
they just laid them out next to each
other
in a in an organized fashion
i like that's what i'm trying to that's
what that's what i'm trying to
understand here i
if if you're trying to find logic in
that 42 seconds of nonsense that we just
listened to everyone's got a grandpa out
there right i mean everyone's kind of
grandpa and you know grandpa reaches an
age where half the time when he's saying
[ __ ] it doesn't make any sense it just
doesn't make any sense he's saying all
kinds of [ __ ] you smile and you nod and
you go yeah grandpa yeah that's a great
story
the only thing is the difference between
my grandpa and this grandpa is my
grandpa didn't violate the [ __ ]
espionage act
well
you know i would also say that probably
for most of our viewers and anyone
watching is that their grandpa
didn't also violate the espionage act
isn't it isn't a treasonous traitor
who stole government documents that were
not his speaking of traders
treasonous traitors uh we had
jeannie thomas the wife of clarence
thomas the supreme court justices
dishonorable mention uh i think i think
this story got buried this week and i'm
glad you made her the dishonorable
mention at the last moment here yeah
because i think this is
important to recognize
as we go into september and these
january 6th select hearings are going to
break out jeannie thomas needs to sit in
the chair hopefully the vice former vice
president mike pence and jeannie thomas
will sit in the chair for questioning
whether it's public or private and i
think they both need to sit for this but
kyle griffin has here breaking
washington it's a washington post story
jeannie thomas pressed lawmakers to
overturn joe biden's 2020 victory not
only in arizona which she emailed 29
lawmakers in arizona as previously
reported but also in a second
battleground state wisconsin
according to the emails obtained under
state public records law so she was
she was really heavily deep in this
state electors um campaign
and i'm telling you i think this is
where the doj is going to pounce on
these son of a [ __ ] and and any
criminals whether it's state federal
these boneheads like
jeannie thomas here um who got
dishonorable mentioned this week for for
finding out that she wasn't doing it in
just one stage she was doing in a bunch
of them and the reason why that's so
significant is because they were trying
to get a slate of electors that could be
switched for president vice president
pence to declare donald trump the
dictator and king
so that's how we got um jeanne johnson
again we talked about this you know uh
when this was yesterday the day before
that this dropped uh but
again
it is insane to think that we have the
wife of a sitting supreme court justice
clarence thomas his wife jenny thomas
was just sexting
with with mark meadows and sending these
seditious texts right going at it and
saying we need to make sure that we
don't make biden president we need to
make sure that donald trump is present
because he's going to save us you know
spreading q anon conspiracy theories
because that's what she is she is a q a
nut
but
the fact that we have someone who not
only was texting mark meadows who was
the chief of staff to donald trump but
was also emailing
arizona
uh to to get those state electors and
then we find out that it was also
wisconsin like i maybe there's more i
wouldn't doubt it for the other swing
states like pennsylvania probably
michigan whatever it might be
but i guarantee that she had further
communication this might be just the tip
of the iceberg and i really do hope the
doj comes in and goes okay enough is
enough as if the other things weren't
enough to show intent
and to show malicious intent to go
against our democracy
but at this point i'm like i hope i hope
they go after her and and make her
testify subpoena her hold her you know
hold her and make her her actually speak
to the questions that the the jan six
committee has because
right now she's just free floating
just i know as an open trader speaking
of flea for flea free floating traders
billbar was apparently just on fox news
this is kind of breaking and he's
talking about the documents and the
boxes that we were just talking about um
let's just let's just uh listen to it
here and see what dummy has to say
i can't think of a legitimate reason why
they they should have been could be
taken out of the uh government away from
the government if they're classified i
frankly am skeptical of this claim that
i declassified everything you know
because frankly
i think it's highly improbable
and second if in fact he sort of stood
over uh scores of boxes not really
knowing what was in them and said i hear
about him classify everything in here
that would be such an abuse uh and uh
that and
show such recklessness that it's almost
worse than taking the documents oh my
god so here is bill barr this piece of
[ __ ] yeah there are this is not this
does not absolve him of anything that he
did by the way no but let me tell you
something when bill barr is going on fox
news
fox news and saying hey
him claiming that he declassified all
this [ __ ] is worse than him taking it
when bill barr says that out loud on fox
news this guy's in big [ __ ] trouble
he's in big trouble and i think bill
barr is signaling to people he's gonna
go to prison
for this dummies you better stop
defending it because he's gonna go to
prison this guy was this guy was one of
the most ruthless trump defenders as the
attorney general of the united states
this is not some [ __ ] schlub this guy
was this guy made sure to bury the
[ __ ] mueller report so that trump
wouldn't be indicted on charges for
russia collusion right or the fact that
that he tried to get bar and bar was
like yeah we'll use the doj to protect
you from eating carol right like with
that lawsuit right i was like whoa whoa
whoa what what are we doing here guys
that is not what you should be using
your power for that scumbag is the one
that's the one who is now saying hey you
need to stop defending this guy because
his argument it doesn't matter which
argument he makes
they're both really treasonous arguments
if i were to quote bill barr right now
it's [ __ ]
right right right well speaking of
[ __ ] uh it brings us to our winner
bone end of the week
elena habba oh my god you talk about
[ __ ] i don't know where she comes up
with these legal takes i don't know
where she got her [ __ ] law degree
from but it doesn't seem like she even
has a law degree to be quite honest with
you i don't think she'll have a law
degree much longer especially you know
especially for christina bob they're
making these accusations i know it's
ridiculous well it's so much so that
they got their own sitcom [ __ ] legal
takes let's watch let's watch this
episode of shitty legal takes here uh
featuring elena habba
[Music]
what what's happened is now they've put
this picture out so that you would
assume and i am somebody who has been
and the press loves to talk about this
especially today i'm somebody that has
been in his office i've seen it this is
not the way his office what has she seen
his office or is it i don't know what it
is i mean it is the office i think as a
lawyer it's important that you are very
specific with your words right right and
it is kind of generic but let's let's
continue
they give you this appearance that you
walk in and there's these top secret
documents just thrown about a b they
don't understand
something that was 2a she says a yep
that was 2a yeah yeah that's the that's
the picture like she's walking straight
into it mark top secret could be mark
classified the presidential records act
he would have said this is declassified
it doesn't get a new marking all the
time he's left the office all the time
and she even admits it doesn't get a new
marking
i mean most of the time
like maybe there's one or two instances
where it didn't that was a mistake and
probably someone paid the price for that
but yeah you know
jesus it is a complete public spectacle
and i'm not really going to stand by it
anymore you know i personally haven't
gotten what's hilarious about the public
spectacle thing is it was them that did
this they made the public spectacle yeah
like literally nara doj wanted to keep
this under wraps they did not want this
out in the public they did not want to
make this a they really didn't want to
do this thing where they released the
photo released it uh the affidavit
released the [ __ ] inventory list they
didn't want to do that they did not want
to do that but even even further back
even further back you have to remember
that in january nara made a visit down
to get those 15 boxes and again like
you're pointing out this whole thing
could have been avoided by one not
stealing the documents right but two
not playing this cat and mouse game for
18 to 20 months and saying we don't have
the documents we swear we don't have the
documents we have written down as a
lawyer representing trump we don't have
the documents we gave you all the
documents you know as they go down and
they go back and forth and nara was like
okay you know what we're just gonna put
this timeline on our website and we're
gonna let everyone know this is the
communication that happened and those
emails were also released because the
lawyers and trump continued to challenge
and say this was all made up they were
the one planning evidence and they're
like look we have the [ __ ] receipts
here they are right we have the emails
back in money when we were talking
what's funny about all this if you
really think about this
the people that are gonna take down
trump here
are [ __ ] librarians okay
literally
librarians at the national and i don't
i'm not trying to they're doing great
work and they catalog everything what
i'm trying to say is librarians usually
are very smart they have great memories
and they document everything they
document everything jesus you take a
book 20 years later they know you still
have that goddamn book yeah and it is
librarians that are going to take down
trump this is hilarious let's continue
to listen to this bonehead intimidated
people have tried to intimidate it's not
going to work you can't just put a
picture like this and say look
did the fbi do that or was that the way
the room looked before they went in
there do you have any any first-hand
knowledge yeah i'm sure you've seen the
press today i do have first-hand
knowledge as you know i have been down
there i'm down there frequently i have
never seen that i have never ever seen
that that is not the way his office
looks anybody that knows president
trump's office he has guests frequently
there it is
it's just a joke they literally must
have gone in and taken out documents
they wanted or cover letters as it is
and put it about so that the public
believes that this is top secret
documents that were on his floor
it's ridiculous i can they were top
secret documents on the same
part out loud
she's like admitting oh my god she's
such a bonehead she goes yeah i went
down there i saw those documents
yeah yeah no i saw i saw those documents
and yeah there were there were frequent
guests that came down there i don't know
guys i don't know what the big deal is
why does why do people keep freaking out
right i have no idea where she got her
law degree and how he found this
attorney i have no idea maybe she snuck
in um with the russian spy who claims to
be a roth child let's give habba her due
for bonehead of the week
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
well gabe it was pretty close between
habba and bob yeah and uh
it was back and forth the whole night i
know i know it was close between the two
of them so thanks for voting for bone
end of the week don't forget to go
follow at tony michael's pod to vote
every single week for bone end of the
week and you can watch bonehead of the
week every single friday here in the
second hour the tony michaels podcast
and also the replay on the midas touch
network's youtube page don't forget to
go over there and subscribe you're not
going to want to miss the replay in
prime time every friday night also
subscribe here at the tony michaels
podcast if you're on minus touch
watching come over to the tony michaels
podcast watch us every single weekday
noon eastern 11 central 9 pacific monday
through friday and also simulcasting at
the midas touch facebook page you can
also download every single episode on
apple spotify google wherever you get
your podcast and listen in make sure to
leave a review while you're there
gabe
it's been a hell of a theme with these
lawyers this week but um we made it
through we made it through the week i'm
sure the weekend's just going to give us
plenty more news on monday yes plenty
more news on monday monday for the
holiday
which by the way are we doing a show on
monday
well i mean i planned on it yeah you
want to take off i'm i'm good to go i
can i've got nothing else going on right
i'll see you on the show all i do is
yell and scream into a microphone that's
all i do is yell and screams and
microphones so join us on monday
if you're here at the tony michaels
podcast stick around but if you're on
the minus touch
youtube channel thanks for joining us
for this edition of bone end of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh bone we went
we made it through we made it through
and we appreciate everyone sticking
around we have a lot of new audience
members again don't forget don't forget
to subscribe here at the tony michaels
podcast that helps us out a lot and go
follow us on twitter as well and all
that helps out at the tony michaels pod
you can also follow me at the tony
michaels and you can follow gabe at i am
gabe sanchez also what helps out is
downloading
every single episode on apple spotify
google your favorite directory you can
listen to us anywhere anytime every
single weekday
and you can leave a review that would be
great too that would help us out and
subscribe that would really help us out
here at the tony michaels podcast and if
you want to support pro democracy speech
go to the link down below support dot
tonymichaelspod.com
uh you can use the qr code but also
support pro democracy speech everywhere
you can not just with monetary uh
contributions but also giving them likes
spreading the message spreading the word
if if they have great messaging
get out there and adopt their messaging
spread their messaging now we've got to
win this midterm it is crucial joe biden
laid it out last night with his speech
why democracy is so important and why
they are so hell-bent on destroying our
democracy because they're fascists
they're fascist yeah so let's do this
let's do the the patriotic thing let's
have a great holiday weekend be safe
be safe this holiday weekend and we will
see you here monday even though it's the
holiday we will see you here on the tony
michaels podcast same time same place
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from the midas touch
facebook page until monday safe weekend
everybody
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking